To help us understand filtering a little bit let's actually not just look at
box filters.
And here, I'm going to actually use a Gaussian filter.
A Gaussian filter,
based on the equation of a Gaussian, it can be used to generate a kernel.
Now in this case, the kernel in this is, is still 21 by 21.
But, the values are normal distribution.
So you notice, more bright values or higher values here.
And as I go away from the center, they get darker.
In the height map we have looking at this,
you will see this to be a little different.
So now if we're for example notice, that there is a peak.
And then there are values, in this one.
Most intensity is here.
Lower ones almost zero here.
And now we want to actually look at this.
And apply this, as a kernel to do, smoothing or filtering operations.
So let's take our example again and
now this time around I'll apply the Gaussian Filter.
Which basically is again, shown by this 21 by 21.
Look at the values that we just saw in the previous slide.
And applied here, you see a result which is also smooth.
But here you might be able to notice that some of the edges have
a little bit more detail.
Again primarily because it's in the linear combination.
It's attribute weight is it's giving more weight to the pixel,
at the center and actually is giving more value to that, and less value in
the linear combination to the values that are away from the center.
So as we rub it, it tries to give more values or
more, more detail at the level, where the center is.
Just for comparison's sake,
I'd like to show you both these results next to each other.
Hopefully your video resolution is good enough for
you to see that this looks a little bit more blurrier than this one.
Just for sake of completeness we're going to zoom into to see some more detail.
Here is the zoom region that I've chosen.
Where the stem of this pepper is the one we want to focus on.
Zooming in, you will see that this one is much more blurred, and
actually just flattened out.
While in this case, you'll see a little bit more of detail.
Now of course, it's not very like the median filter we had looked at before.
But Gaussian filter basically is just a different kernel.
And you can see other details also which are completely lost